good day to your health and jaramillo
with your brief informative for today monday
june 28 the police are investigating the
death of a man inside a
canteen on sunday morning the
shooting happened shortly after three
in the morning in the pity was  near
charleston and queiróz reports
indicate a man shot and killed another
man
before fleeing the bar detectives
say both men had been
at the scene for several hours before the
deadly altercation occurred but had
no interaction during those hours
police are tracking
surveillance videos to determine what
happened and give a description of the
suspect
and in another shooting police are looking for
another person involved in a shooting
inside the sahara hotel the incident
happened on sunday at noon inside
one of the rooms
officers  of the police said that yesterday
the victim of this shooting was
transported to the hospital sant wise where
he is in c  Critical Condition
and Fireworks for
Independence Day Celebrations Go On Sale Today Please
remind the public that the only
rockets allowed in Clark County
carry the zinc-safe label and
are the only ones sold to the public
in all states.  shelves around the
valley not having this label are
prohibited fireworks and
setting them off the fine is up to a thousand
dollars
and now we move on with your
weather forecast a sunny day is expected with
temperatures around 108 degrees for
tomorrow clouds will increase and the
chances of rain have a good
day I am study jaramillo and this was their
brief informative for them now in
Spanish have a good day